[Music]
525 on here Memorial Day what's driving
you crazy how about the next big Formula
One strip repeating closures they
include shifting southbound Las Vegas
Boulevard into split Northbound lanes
and blocking all eastbound Flamingo
drivers from crossing the strip now
Clark County is managing this project
that has led a lot of drivers to just
avoid the area we're talking
particularly about Harman between coval
and the strip now if you don't have a
choice here's what you need to know the
strip shift starts tomorrow night
between Flamingo and Harman scheduled to
wrap up Friday morning at nine now this
eastbound Flamingo closure at Las Vegas
Boulevard that'll start Wednesday night
scheduled to run until Friday night at
midnight so eastbound drivers you'll
only be able to go south in that
Northbound split lane from the Horseshoe
down to Harmon Clark County says that
westbound Flamingo drivers will have
through access at this trip buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com